I've got a real treat for you guys today
this might be the coolest loot that I've
ever seen it's the newest member of my
plucked family this is an arch loot made
by Jose Miguel Moreno in Madrid Spain
and it's just amazing to look at from
the bowl back here which originally
actually comes from an oodback
apparently he fitted it to his new loot
to the extension up here which is just
amazing looking we have a first
headstock here with all double strings
you see lots of of pegs and then we have
a little swan neck extension here with a
very beautiful extension and then a
secondary neck so it's kind of like a
mini fiorbo when you think about it
um we have two instruments in one really
you have the the guitar like part where
you fret the strings here right we touch
the strings here and playing play chords
and whatever and then we have all these
extra bases like a few that just go
lower and lower and lower
[Music]
sounds incredible
the thing that really blows me away
about this instrument the thing that I
can't get over uh is
the natural sympathetic resonation is
insane
um that's kind of like the natural
Reverb on the instrument so check this
out I'm going to play one string and
then instantly stop that string and then
everything else you hear is just a
natural sympathetic resonation of the
other strings vibrating as a result of
the other string normally you get a
little bit of extra sound check this out
foreign
[Music]
it sounds like it's in a cathedral
inside the loot
[Music]
that's insane and so when you play uh
pieces that's kind of happening all the
time and it makes this very very
beautiful almost like natural Reverb to
the instrument
oh foreign
[Music]
get a really good sense of the natural
reverb when I damp the bases because
really a lot of that extra halo effect
is happening because I have all these
extra strings that are open
they're just vibrating and so when I
mute them you can hear a much different
sounding instrument so
thank you
it sounds good it's a nice sound but
when I let go of the bases
foreign
it sounds like it's Amplified or it's
resonating in a church or something
let's listen to a piece played on the
instrument this is a beautiful violin
piece actually by composer named Bieber
not the Bieber you're thinking a baroque
composer who wrote this on violin
apostolia that works very well on orange
loot
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
about getting this instrument from
Madrid but before sharing that story I
just wanted to mention if you're
enjoying my YouTube videos and want to
help support the Channel please do
subscribe I am at the moment 5 000
subscribers away from reaching 400
000 subscribers at which point I'm going
to do a fun twin Reveal video and
introduce all of you to my identical
twin brother who is a singer so please
do subscribe now back to the story I
actually heard of the luthier Jose
Miguel Mourinho from other luteinists
who play as instruments and I was pretty
interested and so while I was in Spain I
decided to pop over to Madrid and meet
him in person play a bunch of his
instruments and I was just so amazed by
the volume of the instruments and then
that natural
that sympathetic resonation I've never
heard an instrument do that before
um to that extent so I decided I wanted
one but I I couldn't buy the instrument
then I couldn't bring it home with me so
normally I would just you know buy a
seat for it and or maybe hope it hope to
fit in the overhead and bring it home
this time I couldn't I had to wait and I
had to ship it but with such a nice
instrument
um it was scary but I went with DHL I
ended up costing a lot more than I
thought it ended up costing me almost
twelve hundred dollars with custom fees
to chip this instrument here so that was
a bummer
um but it made it safely it made it one
piece everything's fine it plays just
like it did when I played it in Madrid I
was frantically checking the tracking
and following it and when it finally
arrived I was so scared when I took it
out of the box I was so nervous that I'd
open it up to a broken instrument with
strings everywhere and Luckily
everything turned out just fine what's
particularly amazing about this
instrument is how the maker somehow
managed to make it super super super
loud if I just
speak normally and play the instrument
at the same time I feel like I have to
talk louder to play over it and normally
with a loot is a pretty quiet instrument
to have one that's quite loud is is kind
of fun because I plan to use this in
playing with orchestras and playing in
operas and things so you need a bit more
volume
and this one gives it to you so the
instrument itself is like a small fiorbo
really except that it's tuned in G
instead of a which means I can play in
all sorts of different Keys when I play
in ensembles like operas or with
orchestras
having a different tuning allows you to
play very easily in different keys but
also the notes go a lot higher so a
fiorbo ends around this B here on the
open strings but a arch Loop
has a b a d and a G above that so it's
very easy to play very high twinkly
beautiful melodies
so this is a 14 course Arch loot an
archloot is a baroque instrument so an
instrument which would have been played
somewhere between say 1600 and 1750 or
so this is of course the newly built
instrument I don't have any historical
loots all of them are replicas and when
I say courses you should know a course
is a pair of strings like on a 12-string
guitar or a mandolin most the courses
have actually two strings when you
actually pluck one so I pluck an a I
actually have two a's so when I pluck
them I pluck them as one and that gives
the loot a very distinct sound that some
of the strings are single so the first
string is always single on loots you can
hear the sound of the first string
[Music]
um sounds you know it sounds good sounds
fine but if I play the double strings
you can you can see it's a different
sound I can actually just play one if I
want
now both
[Music]
at the same time
[Music]
so on this Arch loot I have double
strings on the short neck part so half
of it and then I have single strings on
the basis but the instrument can be
fitted to have double strings on the
bases if I if I want surprisingly for
the length the bass on this thing is
fantastic you get a low F here's another
piece this is actually a Renaissance
piece I just think it sounds really good
on this instrument uh called Mr dowlins
midnight by the famous Elizabethan
composer John daland
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so you'll be seeing a lot more of this
really gorgeous beautiful Arch loot soon
I really love it and I can't wait to
share more with you so stay tuned for
more please check out my patreon if you
want to support this Channel and help me
make more videos if you are interested
in learning classical guitar I have an
online course if you want weekly lessons
I have an online school our pajonto.com
so lots of different ways of helping the
channel or starting your path towards
learning an instrument
in the meantime I'll see you guys next
time take it easy
[Music]